I think that the future media has to be
more disciplined particularly print
media because that have a fantastic
costs associated with producing the
product so the more something costs and
we'll focused you have to be bottom line
and I remain ever more optimistic
because part of what's happening right
now is Darwinian and a lot of magazines
that really shouldn't be on the shelves
are going away but now that said I feel
bad when any fellow publisher goes under
I've had to close the magazine it's a
horrible horrible time in life on many
levels but there are a lot of wannabe in
carbon copy publications that are not
actually you know making a difference in
fact justifying their price secondly the
publishing business is notoriously under
priced itself it sells its advertising
and its copies for less than it costs to
produce the magazine I run the company
that obviously has to change and is
changing whether people like it or not
every hour of the day so I think we'll
be left a magazines actually speak to
people in a way that the internet
doesn't television doesn't radio doesn't
which is not to say that all those other
media don't do a fantastic job and in
many ways a better job in their own
medium but print does an excellent job
of being a place where you lose yourself
in your imagination and a magazine that
understands its audience as I said
earlier will I think continue to to
prosper once it becomes very focused
very disciplined and how it runs its
business
everybody looks at it from one
perspective and only sees down the end
of that line and I'm sure fact if you
stand back and look at all the lines
intersecting it's it's a very very
different picture I think that the New
York media writing will last forever for
the kind of people who really want to
read that and as long as the New Yorker
is discipline that runs its business and
can in fact afford to put out the
product it will continue to keep an
audience it will grow advertisers will
come back to it and they'll stick to it
cuz they realize the audience is engaged
that kind of writing doesn't work
necessarily in a woman's self-help
magazine or a recipe book those things
are different and different animals have
to have different different tracks and
different environments you know you've
got to know what your audience wants if
your music magazine you're not also a
medical magazine and if you're a science
magazine you are partly a medical
magazine if your news weekly you better
be interesting because otherwise you're
anachronistic because the news is now in
use minutes you know and I think some
whole mediums and news week's news
weeklies probably one of them really are
perhaps at this point too anachronistic
to recover that it was also Darwinian
things change you know Life magazine
went away because we saw those pictures
on television that was no longer unique
but I don't think it's it's one flat
line in any respect you know I don't
think fashion magazines everyone's exist
no I think good fashion magazines will
continue to exist for an audience as
eager for that good celebrity magazines
will continue to serve this their
audience and bad sort of your magazines
like okay for instance sorry to label
one will go away
you